From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. So for months now, one of our producers, Ben Calhoun, has been working on one of those stories that starts small, and simple, and personal, and then kind of spins out till a whole town is involved. And I honestly don't want to say too much about this. We should just let it unfold. And so without further ado, here's Ben.
这里是芝加哥 WBEZ 电台的《美国生活》节目，我是艾拉·格拉斯。几个月来，我们的制作人本·卡尔洪一直在追踪报道一个故事。这个故事起初非常微小、简单且私人化，后来却逐渐发酵，最终牵扯到了整个城镇。老实说，我不想剧透太多，我们还是让故事自然展开吧。那么，废话不多说，有请本。
Rob and Reyna Mathis were doing something unusual for parents whose kids had mostly grown up and left home. They were looking to upsize and get more space. Their house wasn't small-- five bedrooms on five acres. But Reyna and Rob have a dozen kids, plus grandkids. And even though most of their children are out of the house, they're the kind of parents adult kids want to spend time with. And they had a vision, a place with enough land that some of their children would build houses right by them.
罗伯和雷娜·马西斯正在做一件对孩子大多已成年离家的父母来说并不寻常的事。他们打算换更大的房子。他们的旧居并不小，有五间卧室，占地五英亩。但雷娜和罗伯有十二个孩子，还有孙辈。尽管大多数孩子已经搬走，但他们是那种成年子女依然乐于共处的父母。他们有一个愿景：找一块地皮足够大的地方，让部分子女能在他们身边盖房子。
By August 2019, they'd been house hunting for months with no luck. And then one day, their Realtor sent Reyna a listing that looked promising. So the Mathises drove out to see it in person on a sunny afternoon. It was pretty far out in the country. They went down a long dirt driveway, back into the woods, until they reached an enormous, sprawling lawn. And Rob looked around.
到2019年8月，他们找房已经好几个月了，但一直没遇到合适的。直到有一天，他们的房产经纪人发给雷娜一个看起来很有希望的房源。在一个阳光明媚的午后，马西斯夫妇驱车前往实地查看。房子在非常偏远的郊区，他们沿着一条长长的土路开进树林，直到看见一片巨大的草坪。罗伯环顾四周。
I was picturing-- I'm like, man, I can see all the kids out here. I'll put a trampoline over there for the grandkids.
我当时就在想——我在想，伙计，我可以想象孩子们在这里奔跑。我会给孙子们在那儿放个蹦床。
Yeah, were you doing the thing where-- I just bought my first house. And I would just start to picture life in those places.
没错，你当时是不是在做那种——我刚买下我的第一套房时，我也会不由自主地开始勾勒在那些地方的生活。
Yep, that's exactly what I was doing. So I'm like, I can make little trails on the property and get some ATVs, and playground over there, buildings right around the property with the family and the kids, and just have a good old time, you know?
是的，我当时就是这么做的。我在想，我可以在院子里修些小径，买几辆全地形车，在那儿建个游乐场，在房产周围盖些给家人和孩子们住的房子，大家一起度过美好时光，你知道吗？
I mean, our wheels were spinning of what we could do with that property.
我的意思是，我们脑子里已经在盘算如何利用那块地了。
As they got out of the car, Reyna looked up at the house, a huge, orange, brick colonial, 4,600 square feet, with two-story brick pillars out front.
当他们下车后，雷娜抬头看向那栋房子，那是一座巨大的、橘红色砖墙的殖民风格建筑，面积达4600平方英尺，门前有两层楼高的砖柱。
When I pulled-- I've always wanted a house with, like, huge pillars and stuff like that. Seeing them pillars, I was like, oh my god, this is it. This is the one. Like, I felt it. I, like, literally felt it. And my son, when he got out, he was smiling. He was like, mom, you got your pillars, you know? So it was like, yeah, that's me right there.
当我停下车——我一直想要一栋有那种大圆柱的房子。看到那些柱子时，我就想，天哪，就是它了。就是这一套。我当时真的感觉到了。那种感觉非常强烈。当我儿子下车时，他也在笑。他说，妈，你终于如愿以偿了，对吧？所以当时就觉得，这就是属于我的房子。
The group that day was six altogether. There was the Realtor, Rob and Reyna, also their youngest daughter, one of their sons, and the son's girlfriend. They walked in the front door, into a big, echoey foyer. And they started looking around. They noticed pretty quickly, the house wasn't really staged as much as it was kind of empty. Like, a lot of stuff had been removed.
那天一共去了六个人。包括房产经纪人、罗伯和雷娜、他们最小的女儿、一个儿子以及儿子的女友。他们走进前门，来到一个宽敞、有回声的门厅，开始四处打量。他们很快注意到，这栋房子看起来并不是精心布置的样板房，反而显得很空。很多家具似乎已经被搬走了。
So as the group walked into the dining room, there wasn't much in it-- a large cat scratching post in the corner, a dark wood dining room table. Rob looked at a little collection of stuff in the middle of the table, some salt and pepper shakers.
当一行人走进餐厅时，里面没多少东西：角落里有个大型猫抓板，还有一张深色木餐桌。罗伯看向桌子中间的一小堆杂物，是一些盐瓶和胡椒瓶。
I'm looking at the table, and the placemat was a Confederate flag.
我看着桌子，发现餐垫竟然是邦联旗图案的。
It was kind of like a-- looked kind of like a glass cutting board, but it was made with a flag in it, you know?
它看起来有点像那种玻璃砧板，但上面嵌着一面旗帜，你懂吗？
Sort of like one of those Pyrex, like, glass things that you put hot pots on or something?
就像那种用来垫热锅的钢化玻璃垫子？
Yeah, yep.
对，就是那个。
The Mathises are an interracial couple. Rob's Black. Reyna's Mexican-American. The two of them convened a discreet, married couple, eye contact conversation. Seems to have gone sort of like, I see it. You see it? OK, we both see it.
马西斯夫妇是跨种族夫妻。罗伯是黑人，雷娜是墨西哥裔美国人。两人交换了一个谨慎的、只有夫妻间懂的眼神。大概意思就是：我看到了。你看到了吗？好，我们都看到了。
I just shook my head. And in my head I was thinking, wow, all right. Everything and everybody has their own opinion. So I'm not even going to pay no attention to this.
我只是摇了摇头。心里在想，哇，好吧。每个人都有自己的观点。但我根本不想理会这个。
So you're just like, let's just keep going, see the rest of the house.
所以你们就想，继续走吧，看看房子的其他部分。
Let's keep on going.
我们继续往下看。
From there, the tour moved on to the living room, where Reyna spotted something else, a jacket hanging up from the Muskegon Police Department. They also spotted a photo of two police officers in uniform. This house, it was out in the country, but it was apparently owned by a police officer who worked in Muskegon, Michigan. That's where the Mathises live. Reyna gave Rob a nudge. Rob looked at the coat and turned to their 21-year-old son who'd come with them.
参观从那儿移步到了客厅，雷娜在那儿发现了另一件东西：一件挂着的马斯基根警察局夹克。他们还看到一张两名警察身着制服的照片。这栋房子虽然在乡下，但显然属于一位在密歇根州马斯基根工作的警察。马西斯一家就住在那里。雷娜推了罗伯一下。罗伯看着那件外套，转头看向同行的21岁的儿子。
I was like, wow, we're in a police house. So I looked at my son. I said, don't touch nothing, you know? I said, don't touch nothing.
我当时心想，哇，我们进了一个警察的家。所以我看着儿子说，别乱碰任何东西，你知道吗？我说，什么都别碰。
This is kind of how Rob is, gruff, funny.
罗伯平时就是这样，直率、风趣。
Yeah, so-- yeah, so he was like, don't touch nothing. So I remember that, because I was laughing. Like, my son is grown.
是的，所以——他当时说，别乱碰任何东西。我还记得那个场景，因为我当时在笑。毕竟我儿子都成年了。
From there, they all went down into the basement, and then into one of the house's two huge garages.
随后，他们一起去了地下室，又去了房子里两个巨大的车库之一。
On the right-hand side of the wall, it was a Confederate flag probably about this big.
在墙的右侧，有一面邦联旗，大概这么大。
Rob held up his hands, like 2 feet by 3 feet.
罗伯比划了一下，大约2英尺乘3英尺。
Then I'm like, man, OK. And when I turned around and looked directly at the wall behind me, it was a flag from the ceiling down here to the floor, a big flag. I'm like, ugh.
然后我在想，伙计，好吧。当我转身看向身后的墙时，从天花板一直到地板挂着一面大旗。我当时就觉得，呃。
There was, like, one flag here, one flag there. And I said something like, this is a lot of flags. And the Realtor kind of just laughed it off, you know? Then I thought, well, OK.
这儿有一面旗，那儿有一面。我说了一些类似“这旗子也太多了”的话。房产经纪人只是笑了笑，试图打圆场，你懂的？但我当时想，嗯，好吧。
So again, I'm looking over at my wife. I'm like, man, I'm not liking this. I'm really not liking this.
所以我又看向我妻子，我说，伙计，我真的很不喜欢这样。我真的很反感。
Rob says he glanced over at his kids to see if they were catching on to any of this stuff, especially his youngest daughter, Asia, who was 12 at the time-- shy, sweet. Rob was kind of relieved to see that none of the kids were noticing any of this.
罗伯说他瞥了一眼孩子们，看看他们是否察觉到了这些，尤其是他当时才12岁的小女儿亚希娅——她很害羞、可爱。看到孩子们没注意到这些，罗伯稍微松了口气。
From there, everyone kind of split up. Rob went upstairs, into one of the bedrooms, with his son Monty, the 21-year-old. And hanging on the wall was a single wood picture frame.
之后，大家分开了。罗伯和21岁的儿子蒙蒂上楼，走进其中一间卧室。墙上挂着一个孤零零的木制相框。
It's the whole empty wall, and there's just one plaque on the wall. So I look up at the picture, and I lean in and look at. I'm like, are you kidding me? This is a KKK application.
整面墙空荡荡的，只有那一个牌匾。我凑近一看。我在想，你在开玩笑吗？这是一份三K党的入会申请书。
It was a framed application from the 1920s to join the KKK. Rob pulled out his phone and took a picture. In the top corners of the paper, there were illustrated white-robed Klansmen on rearing horses thrusting torches into the air. The application read, "I, the undersigned, a native-born, true, and loyal citizen of the United States of America, being a white male Gentile person of temperate habits, sound mind, and a believer in the tenets of the Christian religion, the maintenance of white supremacy, and the principles of pure Americanism, do most respectfully apply for membership." Rob was flustered.
那是一份装裱好的1920年代三K党入会申请。罗伯掏出手机拍了照。纸的顶部角落里画着身穿白袍、骑在马背上的三K党徒，正高举火把。申请书上写着：“我，签署人，一名出生于美国、忠诚的美国公民，作为一名品行温和、心智健全、信仰基督教教义、维护白人至上主义及纯粹美国主义原则的白人男性外邦人，在此恭敬地申请入会。”罗伯慌了。
I say, ah, hell no. We got to go. We got to go. We got to go. So my son was like, what's wrong dad? I said, this is a Klansman house. We're leaving right now. I say--
我说，去他的吧。我们得走。我们必须得走。我儿子问，爸，怎么了？我说，这是一间属于三K党徒的房子。我们现在就走。我说——
Oh, so you said it?
哦，所以你直接说了出来？
I said, it just solidified everything that I was thinking of, that this is what's going on. So when I saw that, that was immediately, let me get my family out of here.
我说，这证实了我之前所有的猜想，看来情况就是这样。所以当我看到那个东西时，我唯一的想法就是立刻带家人离开这里。
All of a sudden, I hear him cussing and coming down the stairs. And he's like, we got to go now. So I'm like, what's going on? And he didn't answer me. He just walked out the door. My son was right behind him.
突然，我听到他在楼上骂骂咧咧地走下来。他说，我们现在就得走。我问，到底怎么了？他没回答我，只是径直走出大门。我儿子紧随其后。
So me and the Realtor went upstairs to see what was going on. And she even got emotional. Like, she started crying. And I was just standing there like, oh my god, is this real? Like, what is going on?
所以我和房产经纪人上楼去看发生了什么。她甚至情绪失控了，开始哭泣。而我就站在那儿想，天哪，这是真的吗？到底发生了什么？
Rob was outside in a spiral of freaking out.
罗伯在外面处于崩溃的边缘。
I said, I don't want to have nothing to do with this house. It's so much hate in this house, I cannot have my family here.
我说，我不想跟这房子有任何瓜葛。这房子里充满了仇恨，我绝不能让我的家人待在这里。
So your mind is just, like, racing through it?
所以你当时思绪混乱，完全失控了？
Just racing through it. I'm like, we have got to go, you know? They probably going to be coming home any minute, or if not, do a drive-by and see all these minorities leaving the house, me a Black man, my wife Hispanic. And our kids are mixed. So I'm like, we got to go.
思绪一片混乱。我在想，我们必须得走，你知道吗？他们可能随时会回来，或者如果不回来，他们开车路过看到我们这些少数族裔从这房子里走出来，我是个黑人，我妻子是拉丁裔，孩子们是混血。所以我说，我们必须得走。
After seeing the application for herself, Reyna came out to talk to Rob.
在亲眼看到那份申请书后，雷娜出来找罗伯谈话。
He said that, you know, he was like, what if there's bodies, you know? What if they held rallies here? He was just saying all kinds of stuff. And I was like-- I didn't even know how to feel. Like, I was upset, I was angry, and I was confused, you know? I just didn't understand why you would-- it was like, all these flags or whatever, how can you not be a racist?
他说，你知道的，他一直在问，如果这房子里有尸体怎么办？如果他们在这儿举行过集会怎么办？他当时语无伦次。我甚至不知道该怎么去感受。我很沮丧，我很愤怒，也很困惑，你懂吗？我就是不明白为什么你会——我的意思是，到处都是这种旗帜之类的东西，你怎么可能不是个种族主义者？
The Realtor also came out with Reyna. She was apologizing over and over, saying she had no idea. This was her first time inside. Reyna found herself trying to make the Realtor feel better.
房产经纪人也跟着雷娜出来了。她不停地道歉，说她根本不知情。这是她第一次进这个房子。雷娜发现自己反而在安慰房产经纪人。
I didn't want her to feel like it was her fault or we were blaming her. So I was trying to talk to her. And then she said-- she started looking at her paperwork. She was like, it's an Anderson, Officer Anderson.
我不想让她觉得是她的错，或者我们在责怪她。所以我试着跟她交流。然后她说——她开始翻看文件。她说，户主姓安德森，安德森警官。
That was the owner of the house, Officer Charles Anderson, who, at the time, was a 21-year veteran of the Muskegon Police Department. I first read about this a couple years ago in the newspaper, the story with the attention-grabbing power of a bad joke. A couple walks into a police officer's house and sees a KKK application on the wall.
那正是房子的主人，安德森警官，当时他已经在马斯基根警察局服役了21年。我几年前在报纸上读到过这个故事，它带着一种恶毒玩笑般的吸引力：一对夫妇走进一位警察的家里，却在墙上看到了一份三K党入会申请。
And from the beginning, I had so many questions, partly because Muskegon, where all this happened, I grew up across Lake Michigan in Milwaukee. And it kind of felt like a place I knew, Rust-Belty, segregated. And I wanted to find out what would happen to the police officer and to this couple who become linked in this awful way after this day in this house.
从一开始，我就有很多疑问，部分原因是因为马斯基根，也就是事情发生的地方，我小时候就在密歇根湖对岸的密尔沃基长大。那地方让我感到熟悉，锈带城市，种族隔离严重。我想弄清楚，那位警察以及这对在这一天之后以这种可怕方式联系在一起的夫妇，后来会经历什么。
It would turn out to be this messy story about race and policing where people's certainty about what's right and wrong would collide with what happens in the real world.
事实证明，这是一个关于种族和警务的混乱故事，人们对是非对错的确定性，与现实世界中发生的事情发生了剧烈碰撞。
And the place that begins is in Rob and Reyna's house when they get home that night in Act 1-- The Decision.
故事的起点，是罗伯和雷娜那天晚上回家后的第一幕——决定。
When we came home, like, Rob was really upset. It was just hard to talk about, because to go there and see something like that-- I mean, I've dealt with racial stuff, but never-- it was like a slap in the face. And then you're an officer. And I just thought, why would you leave that there if you know you have buyers coming to see your home?
回到家后，罗伯非常痛苦。这件事很难启齿，因为去那里看到那样的东西——我的意思是，我经历过种族歧视，但从未有过这种感觉，这简直是当头一棒。而且他还是个警官。我就在想，如果你知道有买家要来看房，为什么要把那种东西留在墙上？
So the Mathises debated whether they should do something, specifically whether they should go public about what they saw, a KKK application hanging up in the home of working police officer. Rob and Reyna have had their share of experiences with police. Reyna isn't shy that she, in particular, was kind of wild when she was younger.
于是马西斯夫妇讨论是否该采取行动，特别是是否应该公开他们所见到的——一份挂在在职警察家中的三K党入会申请。罗伯和雷娜都有过与警察打交道的经历。雷娜从不避讳说，她年轻时比较叛逆。
She's tough, no bull [BLEEP], likes to party. I'm not perfect, she told me. And she had a lot of run-ins with cops, some bad, one violent. But she and Rob both went out of their way to say they think most police officers go to work with good intentions. They do their jobs.
她性格强硬，不容欺负，喜欢派对。我并不完美，她告诉我。她有很多与警察冲突的经历，有些很糟糕，甚至有过暴力冲突。但她和罗伯都特别强调，他们认为大多数警察是怀着好意工作的。他们履行职责。
Rob's retired US Army, a straight arrow. I actually don't know if I've ever seen him without an Army baseball hat on.
罗伯是退伍军人，是个正直的人。事实上，我怀疑我是否见过他摘下那顶陆军棒球帽。
When I put on a uniform and was in the military, you know, I'm doing my job. Freedom ain't free. It's paid with blood and the lives of servicemen just like with the lives of police officers. So I respect them. They're out there trying to protect people. I respect the police and the military with the utmost. I have friends that's police.
当我穿上军装服役时，你知道，我在履行我的职责。自由不是免费的。它是用军人们的鲜血和生命换来的，就像警察们的生活一样。所以我尊重他们。他们身处一线，试图保护民众。我极其尊重警察和军队。我有很多警察朋友。
Here in Muskegon?
在马斯基根吗？
Yeah.
是的。
That just added to Rob's pileup of feelings about all this.
这只会加重罗伯对此事的复杂感受。
And I'm so mad, and I'm upset. And I was like, you know, I got to tell somebody. And I kept-- I'm going back and forth with my wife. I said, man, this officer, whoever home this is, I got to tell at least the people in Muskegon, my friends, that he has Klan memorabilia in his house, he has Confederate flags in his house. And what is your opinion on him doing his job as a police officer and being fair to everybody when he stops them?
我感到非常愤怒和沮丧。我说，你知道，我得告诉某人。我一直——我和我妻子反复商量。我说，伙计，这个警察，不管他是谁，我至少得告诉马斯基根的人，告诉我的朋友们，他的家里有三K党的纪念品，有邦联旗。你觉得他在工作中作为警察，在拦下别人时能公平对待每一个人吗？
Rob and Reyna found themselves on opposite sides of this question about whether to go public. In general, Rob and Reyna seem like a very close, affectionate couple. Like, at some point, I took a spin through Rob's Facebook photos, and they're basically three things-- Rob and Reyna taking selfies together, kissing each other on the cheek, or cracking each other up, pictures of Reyna where Rob's bragging about how beautiful she is, and then there's photos of Reyna's cooking, where he's bragging about how good it is.
罗伯和雷娜发现，对于是否公开此事，他们的观点截然不同。总的来说，罗伯和雷娜看起来是一对非常亲密、恩爱的夫妻。比如，我有一次浏览了罗伯的脸书照片，基本上就是三类：罗伯和雷娜的亲密自拍、互相亲吻脸颊或开怀大笑的照片；罗伯夸赞雷娜有多美丽的照片；还有雷娜做的饭菜，罗伯在炫耀手艺有多好。
Reyna got why Rob wanted to say something about this officer. But she worried, what about backlash? What if things got nasty?
雷娜理解罗伯为什么要曝光这个警察。但她担心：反弹怎么办？如果事态恶化了怎么办？
What if I had something happen here? Do I call the police? That was my biggest fear. Like, they work with him. They've worked with him for years. Are they going to be on my side? Are they really going to try to help me?
如果我在这儿出了事怎么办？我该报警吗？这是我最大的恐惧。他们和他是同事。他们一起工作了很多年。他们会站在我这边吗？他们真的会试着帮我吗？
Rob and Reyna were deciding whether to stick their necks out. It was a version of what I think is a common experience when you aren't white. I say that as an Asian-American. And I know I don't speak for anybody else. But like, things will happen. Little things will happen. Big things will happen.
罗伯和雷娜在决定是否要挺身而出。我想，对于非白人群体来说，这是一种普遍的体验。作为亚裔美国人，我是这么说的。我知道我不能代表任何人。但有些事情就是会发生。小事会发生。大事也会发生。
And you'll have to decide, what's going on here? Is it worth the trouble to say something? Is it worth the blowback? Maybe most of all, will speaking up do any good? Like, what will it accomplish?
你必须决定：这是怎么回事？说出来值得冒这个险吗？反弹值得吗？也许最重要的是，说出来有什么用吗？能达成什么结果？
Rob was arguing principle. Shouldn't we do something about this cop? Reyna was arguing practicality. What'll that mean for us? They go around and around. Eventually, Rob tells Reyna he's going to go pray about it. He goes down into the basement, to his office. After a while, he came to a thought that made up his mind.
罗伯坚持原则。我们难道不该对这个警察采取行动吗？雷娜则在争论现实意义。那对我们意味着什么？他们争论不休。最终，罗伯告诉雷娜他要去祈祷。他走进地下室的办公室。过了一会儿，一个想法让他下定了决心。
I was thinking to myself, OK, what if my son was out riding with his girlfriend, and this officer pulled him over, and snatched him out the car, and did some things that weren't, you know. And it wasn't good, you know? And any person-- it could happen to anybody.
我在想，如果我的儿子和他的女友开车出去，被这个警察拦下，把他从车里拽出来，做了一些不好的事怎么办？那会很糟糕，对吧？任何人都有可能遇到这种事。
Rob just couldn't get past that image, this officer, at night, mistreating a young couple.
罗伯挥之不去那个画面：那个警察在夜里，虐待一对年轻的情侣。
Finally, he came up and he said, I have it on my heart. I feel like I need to warn people. So I said, you know what, I said, if that's what you really feel, I said, then do it.
最后，他走上来对我说，我心里已经有了答案。我觉得我有必要提醒大家。所以我说，你知道吗，如果那是你真实的想法，那就去做吧。
So Rob Mathis drafted a Facebook post, and he showed it to Reyna. "I feel sick to my stomach," he wrote, knowing that he toured the home of, quote, "one of the most racist people in Muskegon, hiding behind his uniform, and possibly harassing people of color." He included a picture of the framed KKK application hanging on the wall.
于是罗伯·马西斯起草了一篇脸书帖文，并给雷娜看了。“我感到恶心，”他写道，因为他知道他参观了“马斯基根最种族主义的人之一”的家，“他躲在制服后面，可能正在骚扰有色人种。”他附上了挂在墙上的三K党入会申请的照片。
Rob and Reyna talked about it, and they made a decision not to name the officer. They posted it. And then the Mathises went to sleep.
罗伯和雷娜讨论了一下，决定不公开这位警察的名字。他们发布了帖文，然后上床睡觉了。
Act 2-- It Begins.
第二幕——开始。
By the time Rob and Reyna woke up, the comments on Rob's post had taken off, exploded actually, to a degree they hadn't expected. There were outraged people supporting them, outraged people criticizing them. Because of the societal disaster that is Facebook, everyone very quickly transposed their culture war baggage onto this situation-- Black lives, blue lives, people, no kidding, arguing about Colin Kaepernick in the comments.
当罗伯和雷娜醒来时，帖文下的评论已经炸开了锅，程度远超他们的预期。有支持他们的愤怒民众，也有批评他们的愤怒民众。因为脸书简直是社会灾难的温床，大家迅速将各自的文化战争包袱投射到这个情况中——关于黑人的命也是命、支持警察的口号，甚至有人在评论区争论科林·卡佩尼克，简直不可理喻。
There was racism, comments like, "lol, what a crybaby-ass Black guy. Probably couldn't afford the house anyways," which aggravated Rob, who was like, our house is worth more than that house. We were going to make money on this move.
评论区充满了种族歧视，比如：“哈哈，多爱哭的黑鬼。反正也买不起这房子。”这激怒了罗伯，他反击说：“我们的房子比那栋贵得多。我们搬家还能赚一笔呢。”
To give you a quick sense of Muskegon, Michigan, it's 38,000 people. The city is blue-collar, Democratic, Rust-Belt, 32% Black. But it's surrounded by rural areas that are heavily White, heavily conservative, where it's not uncommon to see Confederate flags on trucks. The Black population is large enough that it doesn't have political control, but it isn't far from it. And that adds tension to politics, especially in situations about race. It's a divided place in our divided country.
简单介绍一下密歇根州马斯基根，这里有38,000人口。这个城市是蓝领、民主党倾向、处于“锈带”，32%是黑人。但它被周边高度白人化、高度保守的乡村地区所环绕，在卡车上看到邦联旗并不罕见。黑人人口比例虽大，但在政治上没有控制权，但也相差不远。这加剧了政治紧张局势，尤其是在涉及种族的问题上。在我们要分裂的国家里，这是一个分裂的地方。
On Rob's post, a bunch of people argue that having a KKK application in your home was about freedom of speech. "It's a free country," someone wrote. "Not saying I'm OK with the KKK or racism at all, but it's his personal choice to be an idiot. You can't change that." Someone wondered if it was part of a legitimate collection of historical memorabilia. Other people pushed back. "Memorabilia of what, exactly? Memorabilia of killing people of color?"
在罗伯的帖文下，许多人争辩说，在家里放三K党入会申请是言论自由。“这是个自由国家，”有人写道。“我不是说我支持三K党或种族主义，但那是他作为傻瓜的个人选择。你改变不了这点。”有人质疑这是否属于合法的历史纪念品收藏。另一些人反驳道：“纪念什么？纪念杀害有色人种吗？”
People debated about what this meant about the way this officer must be doing his job. Some called for Anderson to be fired. Others called for an investigation. People pleaded for Rob to name the officer, to expose who he was. And Rob did.
人们争论这对于这位警察在工作中表现出的态度意味着什么。有些人要求开除安德森。有些人要求展开调查。人们乞求罗伯说出警察的名字，曝光他是谁。罗伯照做了。
Breaking right now at 6 o'clock, a disturbing discovery, a KKK item found at the home of a Muskegon police officer.
现在是6点钟，为您带来突发新闻：令人不安的发现，在一名马斯基根警察家中发现三K党物品。
The story was on TV news within hours of when Rob posted on Facebook. Reporters were inundating the Mathises and showing up at Anderson's house. One reporter who drove to Anderson's home caught up with his wife, Rachael, at the screen door.
在罗伯发布脸书帖文后的几小时内，故事就上了电视新闻。记者们淹没了马西斯夫妇，并出现在安德森家门口。一位开车到安德森家的记者在纱门前截住了他的妻子瑞秋。
I can't say anything right now. I wish we could, because it would probably set a lot of things straight. But--
我现在不能说什么。我希望我们能说，因为那可能会把很多事情搞清楚。但是——
He's not--
他不是——
Correct.
没错。
He's not a member of the Klan?
他不是三K党成员？
No, he's not.
不，他不是。
OK.
好的。
That'd be the last public word the Andersons said to the media about this. For this story, I reached out to Officer Anderson and his wife many times, called, wrote. Eventually I reached them. Officer Anderson declined to speak about any of this, saying the police unit advised him not to talk. His wife did agree to talk about one aspect of what happened. I'll get to that in a bit.
这将是安德森一家就此事对媒体说的最后一句话。为了这个报道，我多次联系安德森警官和他的妻子，打电话、写信。最终我联系上了他们。安德森警官拒绝就此事发表评论，称警方部门建议他不要开口。他的妻子同意谈谈所发生事情的一个方面。我稍后会讲到。
Act 3-- The People in Charge.
第三幕——负责人。
There were two Muskegon city officials who were going to have to figure out what to do about this situation. There's a police chief, of course, but also this guy named Frank Peterson, Muskegon's city manager. He's the person in charge of running city government, and he'd be part of all the big decisions.
有两位马斯基根市政府官员不得不弄清楚如何处理这个情况。当然，除了警察局长，还有这个人，弗兰克·彼得森，马斯基根的城市经理。他是负责运行市政府的人，也是所有重大决策的一部分。
Frank's an energetic 41, a dad who drinks Mountain Dew on his way to work instead of coffee, an upbeat, let's get it done type. He says the morning after Rob Mathis posted on Facebook, he sat down with the police chief in a windowless conference room at City Hall, just the two of them. They're both White. They were wrestling with this.
弗兰克是一位充满活力的41岁年轻人，一个上班路上喝激浪（Mountain Dew）而不是咖啡的父亲，是个乐观、“让我们把它解决掉”类型的人。他说在罗伯·马西斯发帖的第二天早上，他和警察局长坐在市政厅一间没有窗户的会议室里，就他们两个人。他们都是白人。他们当时很痛苦。
I remember, you know, sitting there at that conference table with the chief. I think it was disbelief and then immediately-- and we-- more angry, right, angry at Charles, going, how could he put us in this situation?
我还记得当时和局长坐在那张会议桌旁的情景。我想那是难以置信，然后立即——我们——更加愤怒，对吧，对查尔斯感到愤怒，心想，他怎么能让我们陷入这种境地？
By Charles, he means the officer, Charles Anderson. Peterson admitted, at first, they weren't asking the question of what this officer believed or did on the job.
他说的查尔斯是指那位警察，查尔斯·安德森。彼得森承认，起初他们并没有问这位警察在工作中是否有种族主义信仰或行为的问题。
You know, it wasn't even about, a-ah, we knew. We thought maybe he was racist. Like, the idea of that it was racist wasn't even in our mind at this point. It was like, I mean, for lack of a better term, just like, how could you be so dumb? You know how could-- how could you be so dumb to put yourself and this community in this position?
你知道，当时根本不是在想“啊，我们早就知道”。我们甚至没想过他是否种族主义。当时的情况是，——恕我直言——就是觉得，他怎么能这么蠢？你懂吗，他怎么能——怎么能这么愚蠢，让自己和这个社区陷入这种境地？
Like, why is that there? And why are you inviting people into your house to see it? Of all the things that we have to do around here, of all the things that-- all the trouble I could get into with decisions I make or don't make, the biggest decision that we had to make now was something that had absolutely-- at the end of the day, had absolutely nothing to do with us. It was something he did off-hours at home. What the heck? You know, just a bonehead decision.
就像，为什么会有那个东西？为什么你要邀请别人到家里去看它？在我们这里要处理的所有事务中，在我做出的或没做出的决定可能带来的所有麻烦中，现在我们要做的最大决定，竟然是关于一件——说到底——与我们毫无关系的事情。那是他下班后在家里做的事。这算什么？你知道，这完全是个愚蠢透顶的决定。
The police chief, beholding that bonehead decision with Peterson that morning, sitting across the conference table, was a guy in his mid 60s named Jeff Lewis. Lewis looks like a baseball GM from the '80s-- floppy hair, mustache. A little context on Lewis-- he was hired as director of public safety in Muskegon 10 years ago. He was brought in as a reformer. He's a community policing guy.
那天早上与彼得森坐在会议桌对面、目睹那个愚蠢决定的警察局长，是一位名叫杰夫·刘易斯的60多岁老人。刘易斯看起来像80年代的棒球总经理——头发蓬乱，留着胡子。关于刘易斯的背景——他10年前被聘为马斯基根公共安全主管。他作为改革者被请来。他是个倡导社区警务的人。
During his 10 years as chief, he's added body cams, improved the department's dash cams, implemented tougher psychological screening for hiring, and significantly increased the number of non-White officers, though its still pretty low, about a tenth of the force. When this situation popped up with Officer Anderson's house, Lewis didn't dither.
在担任局长的10年里，他增加了随身摄像机，改进了部门的行车记录仪，对招聘实施了更严格的心理筛查，并显著增加了非白人警察的数量，尽管比例依然很低，约为警力总数的十分之一。当安德森警官房子的这件事爆发时，刘易斯没有犹豫。
The first thing I did, my instant move, was to remove him from the patrol division right then. I didn't come in the next day, and we didn't spend time reviewing this. I instantly put him on what we call paid administrative leave so no further damage could happen.
我做的第一件事，我的即刻反应，就是立刻将他从巡逻部门撤职。我没有拖到第二天，我们也没花时间去复核。我立刻让他处于我们所谓的带薪行政休假状态，以免造成进一步损害。
Can't come back to department. Turn your badge and gun in, so on and so forth. And then you just go back to your civilian life. And then we look into it.
不能回警局。交出警徽和枪支，诸如此类。然后你回到你的平民生活。然后我们展开调查。
Chief Lewis pulled in his internal affairs team and ordered them to start an investigation. First thing he wanted was the basic facts. Was this Facebook thing true? Did Officer Anderson have this stuff up in his house, and why? That first day, the city released a short public statement, basically the standard, the officer's on leave. We're investigating. More later.
刘易斯局长召集了他的内务调查小组，命令他们开始调查。他首先想要了解基本事实。脸书上的事是真的吗？安德森警官真的在家里放了那些东西吗？为什么？第一天，市政府发布了一份简短的公开声明，基本是标准套路：该警官正在休假。我们正在调查。稍后会有更多信息。
Act 4-- We Know That Guy.
第四幕——我们认识那家伙。
Turns out the officer involved here was already famous in Muskegon, for another controversial incident, even before the Mathises posted online. Though Rob and Reyna didn't realize that when they heard his name.
事实证明，涉案的这位警官在马斯基根早就很有名了，甚至在马西斯夫妇发帖之前，他就曾卷入另一起争议事件。尽管罗伯和雷娜听说他名字时并没意识到这一点。
The officer at the center of this also has a controversial past. 10 years ago, he shot and killed a man.
处于此事核心的这位警官过去也很有争议。10年前，他开枪打死了一个人。
The man Anderson shot was 23-year-old Julius Johnson. It started when Muskegon police pulled over a car at 1:30 in the morning near--
安德森开枪打死的那个人是23岁的朱利叶斯·约翰逊。起因是马斯基根警察在凌晨1点半拦下了一辆车，地点靠近——
What happened? This was in 2009. During a traffic stop, a young man, Julius Johnson, who people called JuJu, dropped a bag of drugs and ran. Anderson chased Johnson down a dark street, tackled him, fought with him. Anderson said Johnson started winning, and he shot him in self-defense.
发生了什么？这是在2009年。在一次交通检查中，一名叫朱利叶斯·约翰逊的年轻人，也就是人们口中的JuJu，扔掉了一袋毒品后逃跑。安德森追赶约翰逊进入一条黑暗的街道，将其扑倒并扭打。安德森称约翰逊开始占上风，于是他出于自卫开枪打死了他。
Johnson's sister lived on that block. She said she saw everything, and Anderson was lying.
约翰逊的妹妹住在那条街上。她说她目睹了一切，安德森在撒谎。
And my brother said, please do not shoot me. And they shot him-- cold blood, just shot him.
我哥哥说，请不要开枪。然后他们就开枪了——冷血，直接开了枪。
The Muskegon County Prosecutor's office investigated the shooting and her allegations and turned up a security camera recording that backed up Anderson's version of the story. And so he was cleared. Prosecutors actually brought charges against Johnson's sister for lying, and she went to jail for that.
马斯基根县检察官办公室对枪击事件和她的指控进行了调查，并发现了一个安全摄像头记录，证实了安德森的故事版本。于是他被免罪了。检察官甚至以撒谎为由起诉了约翰逊的妹妹，她为此坐了牢。
I talked to the head of the local NAACP about the JuJu Johnson shooting. He's a retired Muskegon police officer and a big police reform proponent. He said Anderson chasing Johnson, getting himself into that fight, that was questionable policing, noting Johnson was well-known. Would have been easy to track him down later and arrest him. But given the evidence, in terms of police policy, it was, quote, "a good shooting."
我跟当地全美有色人种协进会（NAACP）的负责人谈过JuJu·约翰逊枪击案。他是一名退休的马斯基根警察，也是警察改革的大力倡导者。他说安德森追捕约翰逊并陷入那场搏斗，是值得怀疑的警务行为，并指出约翰逊是当地名人。本来很容易在那之后追踪他并实施逮捕的。但根据证据，从警务政策的角度来看，这是一次“合法的枪击”。
Still, even though Anderson was cleared, as soon as the Mathises posted about the KKK application in Anderson's house, people were calling him JuJu's killer in the comments. It was like these two things clicked together, like they explained each other. People were like, see, I knew it. That guy's racist.
尽管如此，即使安德森被免罪，当马西斯夫妇发帖曝光安德森家中的三K党申请书后，评论区的人们开始叫他“朱朱的杀手”。这就好像这两件事拼凑在一起，互为解释。人们说：看，我早就知道。那家伙是个种族主义者。
City officials had to confront all of this in a new way not even a week after the Mathises posted. Muskegon was scheduled to have a city commission meeting, which usually are pretty sleepy, but not this one.
马西斯夫妇发帖不到一周，市政府官员就不得不以一种全新的方式面对所有这些质疑。马斯基根原定召开一次市政委员会会议，通常这类会议都很冷清，但这回不然。
[GAVEL SOUNDING]
[木槌敲击声]
Good evening, everyone. I know that we probably do have a number of individuals that are here due to the concern with one of Muskegon's police officers.
大家晚上好。我知道我们今天有很多市民来到这里，是因为对马斯基根的一位警察感到担忧。
People took turns talking, all of them concerned, upset. No one was there to support Anderson. What struck me the most watching it was that three out of the seven people who spoke about Anderson said that they had personally had bad experiences with him, they, themselves. Like, there was a woman named Ebony Davis, who's Black. She's one of Muskegon's leading activists around all kinds of issues, definitely race and policing.
人们轮流发言，大家都感到忧虑和不安。没有人支持安德森。最让我感到震撼的是，发言的七个人中，有三个说他们自己亲身经历过安德森的恶行。比如一位叫埃博妮·戴维斯的女性，她是黑人。她是马斯基根在各种议题上的主要活动人士之一，尤其是在种族和警务方面。
Ebony brought a petition signed by a thousand people calling for Anderson to be fired. But she also said that just the other week, she, herself, had witnessed Anderson doing something messed up.
埃博妮带来了包含一千人签名的请愿书，要求开除安德森。但她还提到，就在上周，她亲眼目睹了安德森做了一件糟糕透顶的事情。
Officer Anderson has a history of harassing minorities and being very cocky. I've seen it with my own eyes. I even threatened to report him. And he laughed at me and said, nothing's going to happen to me.
安德森警官有骚扰少数族裔且非常狂妄的历史。我亲眼见过。我甚至威胁要举报他。他嘲笑我说：“没谁能把我怎么样。”
Ebony told me later that she and another woman had actually gone to City Hall. And they were in the middle of filing an official complaint when they saw the Mathis' post about the KKK application. They were both like, wouldn't it be crazy if this was the same officer we're complaining about? It seemed so nuts, they both laughed.
埃博妮后来告诉我，她和另一名妇女当时正前往市政厅。她们正准备提交正式投诉时，看到了马西斯发的关于三K党申请书的帖子。她们当时都想：如果这正是我们正在投诉的那位警察，那该多疯狂啊？这看起来太离谱了，两人都笑了。
After Ebony, a gentle-looking guy in glasses named Lowell Kirksey came to the mic.
埃博妮发言后，一位戴着眼镜、看起来很温和的名叫洛厄尔·柯克西的人走到了麦克风前。
Mr. Kirksey.
柯克西先生。
Now city officials knew Lowell Kirksey. He's a retired city employee, ran the city's youth rec programs for years. Lowell said he'd crossed paths with Anderson three times. Once, Anderson had come to his house over something minor, a construction permit, and was weirdly aggressive. He said his neighbor had a bad incident with him too. And then there was this thing at City Hall.
市政府官员认识洛厄尔·柯克西。他是退休的市政雇员，多年来一直负责市里的青少年康乐项目。洛厄尔说他曾三次与安德森打过交道。有一次，安德森因为一件小事（建筑许可）来到他家，表现出奇怪的攻击性。他说他的邻居也经历过糟糕的事情。然后就是在市政厅发生的那件事。
As a city employee, we faced having to deal with Officer Anderson driving his truck onto city property with his Dixie flag showing. But for many of the Black employees of the city at the time, it was very disturbing for us to see that. And during--
作为市政雇员，我们曾面临不得不处理安德森警官开着他的卡车开进市政府大院，上面挂着迪克西旗（邦联旗）的情况。对于当时市里许多黑人员工来说，看到那个景象非常令人不安。
Lowell later explained to me this thing happened around the time Barack Obama was elected. Anderson started driving around with a big Confederate flag all the way across the back window of his pickup truck, parking it like that at City Hall. Lowell and other Black employees complained about it. Then it stopped.
洛厄尔后来向我解释，这件事发生在巴拉克·奥巴马当选前后。安德森开始开着一辆皮卡车四处转悠，车后窗横着一面巨大的邦联旗，并把它停在市政厅。洛厄尔和其他黑人员工为此抱怨。后来才停止。
But Lowell's point was none of this was news. The signs were there, sitting out in the open. Like, maybe it shouldn't have required the Mathises finding a KKK application on his wall for someone to scrutinize this police officer.
但洛厄尔的观点是，这些根本不是新闻。迹象一直都在，明明白白地摆在那儿。也许不应该等到马西斯夫妇在他墙上发现三K党申请书，才有人去审视这位警官。
In the room, listening to all this testimony, were the police chief, Jeff Lewis, and Muskegon city manager, Frank Peterson. Peterson was actually up on the dais. He told me he and Chief Lewis were texting back and forth while people spoke, and they were alarmed by what they were hearing.
在房间里听证会的还有警察局长杰夫·刘易斯和马斯基根城市经理弗兰克·彼得森。彼得森当时坐在主席台上。他告诉我，他和刘易斯局长在听大家发言时一直在互发短信，他们听到的内容让他们感到震惊。
A lot of people were saying, wait a minute, I know that person. He dealt-- he treated me this way. He called me this. That's when it became kind of real to me. It was, holy smokes, this officer, over the last 15 years, he could have interacted with 5,000 people, 5,000 different interactions. And were three of them bad, and we just happened to hear about them finally? Or were 30% of them, you know, bad?
很多人都在说：等一下，我认识那个人。他对待我的方式是这样的。他叫我那个……。那让我意识到这件事的严重性。我心想，天哪，这位警官在过去15年里可能与5000人有过互动，5000次不同的互动。其中有3次是糟糕的，而我们只是恰巧听到了？还是说其中30%都是糟糕的？
You know, it really helped you see the scope, right, of how difficult it was going to be to validate or invalidate the concerns that people had, that maybe they weren't high enough-- a high enough level of mistreatment to where they resulted in a formal complaint, but they were obviously happening, or appeared that they were obviously happening.
这真的让你看清了范围，对吧？要验证或否定人们的担忧有多难，也许那些不满程度还没达到正式投诉的级别，但它们显然发生了，或者看起来显然在发生。
So the question now facing the city was the question that was kind of baked into this from the start, from the moment Rob and Reyna saw that stuff in Officer Anderson's house. Did that KKK application on Charles Anderson's wall correspond to 21 years of mistreating people on the job?
所以现在城市面临的问题，从一开始就隐含在内——从罗伯和雷娜在安德森警官家里看到那些东西的那一刻起。查尔斯·安德森墙上的那份三K党申请书，是否对应着他21年来在工作中虐待民众的行为？
That brings us to Act 5 of our story, Officer Anderson On the Job.
这带我们进入故事的第五幕：安德森警官的工作表现。
I heard a pile of stories of the way Officer Anderson did his job, and I'm going to tell you one of them. Because it's a great example of how he could be. This thing that happened, happened to a man named Hamid Stalling, who everyone calls Duke. These days, Duke's in real estate, a family guy, married with four kids that he dotes on. Duke and his family are Black.
我听过一堆关于安德森警官如何执行工作的故事，我要讲其中一个。因为这是一个很好的例子，说明他可能是个什么样的人。这事发生在一个叫哈米德·斯托林的人身上，大家都叫他“公爵”（Duke）。如今，公爵从事房地产，是个居家好男人，已婚，有四个让他视若珍宝的孩子。公爵一家是黑人。
Duke told me he remembers the day he saw the story about the Mathises, how they saw a KKK application in a Muskegon police officer's house. So Duke says he's reading that.
公爵告诉我，他记得看到马西斯夫妇关于在一位马斯基根警察家中发现三K党申请书报道的那天。公爵说他当时在读那个新闻。
And seeing that there was an officer that had a KKK artifact, whatever in the house-- I hadn't got to his name, because they didn't mention his name right away. I hadn't got to that part. Ding, ding, ding, though, his name first came in. I didn't even read his name. I knew it was him. Something in my spirit said, it's Anderson. It was Anderson.
看到有一位警察家里有三K党的文物之类东西时——我还没看到名字，因为新闻没马上提。我还没读到那部分。但叮的一声，他的名字出现了。我都没读名字，我就知道是他。我的直觉告诉我：就是安德森。就是安德森。
And it was like there was a joy. At the same time, there was a sadness. Because I said, well, how did they let this guy continue to do this before somebody had to have this kind of evidence to where--
当时有一种喜悦，同时也有一种悲伤。因为我在想：在必须有这种证据才能证明他是谁之前，他们怎么能让这家伙继续这样做？
Duke's run-in with Officer Anderson happened in the summer of 2010. At the time, Duke was 24. And he says life was good. He'd recently become the pastor at a small church, Zion Blue Lake Baptist, which he was really excited about. And he was working at an office furniture company on the assembly line. His bosses loved him, and they were on the verge of promoting him.
公爵与安德森警官的冲突发生在2010年夏天。当时公爵24岁。他说那时候生活很美好。他刚成为一家小型教会（锡安蓝湖浸信会）的牧师，对此感到非常兴奋。他还在一家办公家具公司做流水线工作。老板们很看重他，即将给他升职。
And then on July 8, 2010, Duke's mom, Earline, had her 59th birthday party in her backyard. It was a family and friends kind of thing, her brothers and sisters, nieces and nephews, little boom box playing the OJ's and Teddy Pendergrass, a little bit of dancing.
然后在2010年7月8日，公爵的母亲厄琳在后院举办了她的59岁生日派对。那是家人和朋友的聚会，她的兄弟姐妹、侄子侄女都在，小收音机播放着欧杰斯和泰迪·潘德格拉斯的歌，大家跳跳舞。
Earline was a devout Christian, grew up in the Baptist church. She didn't drink, didn't smoke. It was tame. Around midnight, everything had wound down, maybe 15, 20 people left, mostly Duke's aunts and uncles. And Duke was on the front steps talking to a relative when an officer-- this was Officer Anderson-- pulled up in a police cruiser alone and started approaching the house.
厄琳是个虔诚的基督徒，在浸信会教堂长大。她不喝酒，不抽烟。派对很平淡。午夜时分，一切都结束了，大概剩了15到20个人，主要是公爵的姑姑和叔叔们。公爵正站在前台阶上和一个亲戚聊天，一名警察——就是安德森警官——独自开着巡逻车过来，开始靠近房子。
Duke says he started towards the backyard to get his parents. But Anderson kind of stepped in front of him on the sidewalk next to the house. Duke asked, is everything OK?
公爵说他开始走向后院去找父母。但安德森拦住了他。公爵问，一切都好吗？
So when I come up to him and I ask him, you know, is everything OK, the first thing he says is, are you the owners of this property? And I said, um, well can you tell me what's going on? He was like, are you the owner? I said, no, but can you tell me going on? That's what got him mad. And that's when he said, do you want to go down for what's about to happen?
当我走向他问他“一切都好吗”的时候，他说的第一句话是：“你是这房子的主人吗？”我说：“嗯，你能告诉我发生什么了吗？”他问：“你是主人吗？”我说：“不，但你能告诉我发生什么了吗？”那让他火冒三丈。然后他说：“你想体验一下接下来会发生什么吗？”
It was an odd thing to say, do you want to go down for what's about to happen? It startled Duke.
这是一个奇怪的说法，“你想体验一下接下来会发生什么吗？”这让公爵很吃惊。
Now I'm scared. Because I'm like, what? What's about to happen? I don't want to know. I don't want no problem. So let me go get somebody that's older that can deal with this. I don't even know what's going on, because he won't say what's going on.
我当时很害怕。因为我在想：什么？接下来会发生什么？我不想知道。我不想惹麻烦。所以我去叫个长辈来处理。我甚至不知道发生了什么，因为他什么都不说。
Duke says he walked down the little sidewalk next to the house, towards the backyard, to get his parents. When he gets to the yard and goes to close the gate behind him, Anderson's right there and kicks the gate back open, hard. Like, there was a bang.
公爵说他沿着房子边的小人行道走到后院去叫父母。当他到达后院并关上门时，安德森就在后面，用力猛地踹开了大门。砰的一声巨响。
This is the gate, right? So we were about right here. This is where we were, about right here.
这是那扇门，对吧？我们当时就在这儿。
Duke's mom passed away in 2014. Now he owns the house. So he took me outside to show me how things happened in the backyard that night.
公爵的母亲于2014年去世。现在他拥有这栋房子。他带我到外面演示那天晚上后院发生的事情。
My uncle Dune was sitting over here. Some people were sitting down. His wife was sitting in the rocking swing. Two other people, they were just over here talking.
我叔叔杜恩坐在这儿。有人坐着。他妻子坐在摇椅上。还有两个人坐这儿聊天。
Duke could point to where everything was at that moment, the lights strung around the fence, the picnic tables, where the food was, where the cake was.
公爵能指出当时每个人在哪里，围栏上的灯，餐桌在哪里，食物在哪里，蛋糕在哪里。
And you had some people sitting over here talking. You had maybe, like I said, two or three people dancing. Because it's getting late. It's not really a lot of up, moving, dancing no more. But that's all it was.
还有一些人坐这儿聊天。可能有两三个人在跳舞。因为当时很晚了。并没有太多的剧烈运动。但当时就是这样。
I don't mean this in a funny way, but it sounds like old people sitting.
我没别的意思，但听起来像老人们坐着休息。
[CHUCKLING] Yeah, I was really trying to say that, but I didn't want to-- yeah, that's really what I was saying. Yeah, it was old people sitting, eventually about to get ready to go. Because I mean, we probably had another 30 minutes left for them. All right sister, see you later. It was about to be over with.
[轻笑] 是的，我本来想说，但我不想——是的，我就是这个意思。老人们坐着，准备走了。因为我们可能也就剩下30分钟了。好的姐妹，再见。派对快结束了。
In Anderson's police report, he says Duke slammed the gate on him to push him back, keep him out. He did that twice. Anderson would later have Duke charged with assault for this. Duke says he just wouldn't have done that to a police officer. He was worried. He was scared. He didn't want trouble.
在安德森的警察报告里，他说公爵为了阻挡他，把门撞在他身上，把他挡在外面。他做了两次。安德森后来以袭击罪指控公爵。公爵说他绝不会那样对待警察。他很担心，他很害怕。他不想惹麻烦。
After that, Duke and Anderson's stories mostly line up. Anderson writes in his report that he shoved his way into the yard, yelled that Duke was under arrest and going to jail. Duke says his aunts and uncles were like, whoa, whoa, whoa, what is going on? They put their arms in front of Duke to protect him from Anderson.
在那之后，公爵和安德森的故事大体吻合。安德森在报告里写道，他闯进院子，大喊公爵被捕了，要进监狱。公爵说他的姑姑和叔叔们不知所措，问发生了什么。他们伸出胳膊挡在公爵面前保护他。
And now there's just a bunch of exchanges from him, you're going to jail, da-da-da-da-da. And they're yelling, what did he do? He's not going to jail. He didn't do anything.
然后就是一大堆争吵，你要坐牢了，巴拉巴拉。他们喊着：他做了什么？他不会坐牢的。他没做任何事。
In his report, Anderson describes the crowd as irate. Duke says people were just confused and upset.
在报告里，安德森将人群描述为“愤怒”。公爵说大家只是感到困惑和不安。
Like, they were not causing any harm to him at all. They wouldn't cause any harm to him. They wouldn't do anything to him. Like, nobody's crazy enough to hit a police. Like my family, we're not crazy. Nobody's going to put their hands on a police officer or anything like that. And then that's when the mace came out. And, shh, he sprayed.
他们并没有伤害他。他们绝不会伤害他。他们什么都没做。没人会疯到去打警察。我家人不疯。没人会动手碰警察。然后就是胡椒喷雾拿出来了。嗤，他喷了。
It was pepper spray. Duke remembers a few of his aunts, women in their late 50s, got the worst of it. And then it was chaos.
是胡椒喷雾。公爵记得他几个姑姑，那些快60岁的女人们遭了殃。然后是一片混乱。
You had people falling, of course, and trying to run to get-- you know, you can't see. You're rubbing your eyes. That's scary. It's a scary feeling. Some people fall. Some, I can't see. You hear a bunch of screaming.
有人摔倒了，试图逃离——你看不见。你揉着眼睛。那很可怕。那是一种恐惧的感觉。有人跌倒。有些喊着“我看不见”。你能听到一阵尖叫。
And so now, but then when that happens, the officers, I don't know how-- I mean, it didn't take them long to get here. I mean, it was like every officer from the precinct.
发生这种事后，警察们，我不知道怎么——反正没过多久他们就到了。就像辖区里所有警察都来了。
They handcuffed Duke and took him away. Duke didn't have a record, didn't understand what he'd done. They booked him for non-aggravated assault. For months, it seemed like Duke might go to jail, until the charges were finally thrown out. It all kind of wrecked his life for a while. Duke stepped down as pastor of that church. He's convinced the company he was working for didn't renew his contract because they saw his mug shot in the paper.
他们给公爵戴上手铐把他带走了。公爵没案底，不知道自己犯了什么法。他们以“非严重袭击罪”起诉了他。有好几个月，公爵似乎都要坐牢，直到指控最终被撤销。这一切让他生活崩溃了一阵子。公爵辞去了那个教会牧师的职位。他确信他工作的公司因为报纸上刊登了他的入狱照而没续签合同。
As you make sense of what happened that night at Duke's mom's, consider what Officer Anderson was reportedly there for. It's listed in police records as a noise complaint. Consider how differently this could have gone if, for example, Anderson had told Duke in front of the house, there's been a noise complaint. I'm just here to ask you guys to keep it down, or when Duke said he was going to get his parents, if Anderson had waited and then told his mom.
当你试图理解那天晚上在公爵妈妈家里发生的事时，考虑一下安德森警官据称是因为什么去的。警方记录中将其列为“噪音投诉”。考虑一下，如果安德森在房子前对公爵说“有人投诉噪音，请降低音量”，或者在公爵说要去找父母时，如果安德森等一下并告诉他的母亲，情况会有多大不同。
His mom, Earline, she knew all her neighbors well. Duke's confident she would have told people, keep it down, and they would have just wrapped things up. When Anderson entered the yard and people wanted to know why he was there, if he'd said, this is not a big deal. I'm just here over a noise complaint, rather than shouting Duke was under arrest and going to jail. But instead, officer Anderson took this tiny complaint and, at so many points, he escalated it. And he ended up pepper spraying a 59-year-old woman's family birthday party.
他的母亲厄琳很了解所有邻居。公爵确信她会告诉大家保持安静，大家会和平结束聚会。当安德森闯入院子而人们想知道他为什么在那里时，如果他说“这没什么大不了的，我只是来处理噪音投诉”，而不是大喊公爵被捕要坐牢。安德森警官却把这微小的投诉在许多节点升级了。最终，他向一个59岁女人的家庭生日派对喷了胡椒喷雾。
Something else I want to point out about this story-- it might be the best example out there of how Muskegon city government might have taken a harder look at Anderson years before the KKK application was spotted in his house. Because Duke and four of his relatives filed formal complaints. They tried to raise the alarm about the kind of officer Anderson was.
关于这个故事，我还有一点想指出——这可能是马斯基根市政府早在那份三K党申请书被发现前，本可以更严厉审查安德森的最好例子。因为公爵和他的四名亲戚正式提交了投诉。他们试图警示安德森是哪种警官。
The department ended up dismissing their complaints and clearing Anderson of any wrongdoing. It did that based on the word of two officers who'd shown up as backup and who hadn't seen a lot of what happened. Duke says no one from the police department ever reached out to him or his family. No one ever called to ask questions, Duke told me, nobody, never.
部门最终驳回了他们的投诉，并判定安德森无罪。结论基于两名作为后援赶到、且没看到很多事情经过的警察的说法。公爵说警局没人联系过他和家人。没人打过电话问问题，公爵告诉我，没人，从来没有。
Duke says he felt stymied and powerless. And in his faith, he thought, God, I'm going to leave it in your hands. And something is going to come to light. And they're going to see who he really is. That was literally his prayer, he said. People don't believe me, so that's going to be my justice.
公爵说他感到受挫且无力。基于信仰，他想：上帝，我把它交给你了。真相终会大白。他们会看到他到底是什么样的人。这就是他的祈祷。他说，没人相信我，所以这就是我的正义。
And so when the Mathises came forward about the stuff in Anderson's house, Duke thought, this is the day he was hoping for. I didn't want anything bad to happen to him, he told me. I wanted the light to be shown. And people would see who he was.
所以当马西斯夫妇站出来曝光安德森家中的东西时，公爵想：这就是他期待已久的日子。他告诉我，我不想他遭遇不幸，我想让真相大白。让人们看清他到底是谁。
Ben Calhoun. Coming up, Officer Anderson explains about the KKK application to other policemen and how taking a stand and speaking out works out for the Mathises. That's in a minute, from Chicago Public Radio, when our program continues.
本·卡尔洪。接下来，安德森警官向其他警察解释那份三K党申请书，以及马西斯夫妇站出来说话后的结果。稍后继续，来自芝加哥公共广播电台的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's program-- A Couple Walks Into a House. The story of the fallout in one town when a couple, the Mathises, spots some Confederate flags and a framed KKK application in a policeman's home. I just want to say before we go further, so much happens in this story. There are so many people and moments worth documenting, and also a few very weird plot twists to come, that we're going to tell this over two episodes starting today and finishing next time.
这是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目——一对夫妇走进一间房子。故事发生在马斯基根，一对夫妇马西斯夫妇在一位警察的家里发现了邦联旗和一份装裱好的三K党申请书。在继续之前，我想说这个故事中发生了太多事情。有太多值得记录的人和时刻，也有一些非常诡异的剧情反转，所以我们将分两集来讲，今天开始，下次结束。
So one result of the Mathis' original Facebook post alerting people about the stuff in Officer Anderson's house, something they were glad to see, was that for the first time in this veteran cop's two-decade history on the force, city officials were now looking seriously into whether he was mistreating Black people on the job. So in terms of results for them, that is something.
马西斯最初在脸书上提醒人们关注安德森警官家里的东西，这是他们乐于见到的结果之一：这位老练警察在警队服役二十年历史上，市政府官员第一次认真调查他是否在工作中虐待黑人。所以就结果而言，这算是一点收获。
But there were other results too, which brings us to Act 6 of our story, Things Get Ugly. Again, here's Ben Calhoun.
但也有其他结果，这带我们进入故事的第六幕：事情变得丑陋。再次有请本·卡尔洪。
These weeks while the city's investigation unfolded were bad ones for Rob and Reyna Mathis. The backlash that Reyna had worried about when they posted about Officer Anderson, it came, and it was awful. Muskegon, at 38,000 people, is just large enough to have city problems, but also small enough that people are in your business and recognize you at the grocery store. It's a hard place to hide, especially if your face is all over the biggest news story in town.
在城市调查展开的这几周里，对罗伯和雷娜·马西斯来说非常糟糕。雷娜在发布关于安德森警官的消息时所担心的反弹真的来了，而且很可怕。马斯基根有38,000人，规模刚好足够有城市问题，也足够小到让人窥探你的隐私，在超市里都能认出你。在这个地方很难隐藏，特别是当你的脸成了城里最大新闻的主角时。
Rob and Reyna say as soon as they went public, the threats started. Some of it was trolling and stuff they could shrug off, people they didn't know calling them on Facebook Messenger, randos in other parts of the country making threats. But some was ugly, racist, genuinely scary.
罗伯和雷娜说，他们一公开，威胁就开始了。有些是他们可以一笑置之的恶意骚扰，互不相识的人在脸书Messenger上打电话，外地的人发出威胁。但有些非常丑陋、带有种族歧视，真正让人感到恐惧。
Well, there was one post where someone took a picture of my daughter, the one that you've just seen, my daughter Asia. She was 12 at the time. She was playing-- we have a Yorkie. And she was playing in the front yard with the Yorkie. And someone posted a picture of her playing with the dog saying, we know where you live, and posted the picture.
好吧，有一次有人拍了我女儿的照片，就是你刚才见到的那个，我的女儿亚希娅。她当时12岁。她正在——我们养了只约克夏犬。她在前院跟狗玩。有人贴出她跟狗玩的照片，说“我们知道你住哪儿”，并贴出了那张照片。
One thing to know, the Mathis' house sits in the woods more than 500 feet off the road. To get that picture, whoever this person was had driven all the way back and taken a photo without Rob or Reyna noticing they were there. After that, they sent their daughter to stay with an aunt.
有一点要说明，马西斯的房子位于离公路500多英尺的树林里。为了拍那张照片，这个不知名的人驱车一直开到后面，在罗伯和雷娜毫无察觉的情况下拍了照。在那之后，他们把女儿送到阿姨家避难。
Soon, things started happening in person. Young White men in a car at a stoplight recognizing Rob and Reyna, shouting a bunch of threats, and then speeding off. A couple in a parking lot came up to Reyna, her youngest daughter, and her six-year-old grandson and started yelling, using the N-word. One morning, when Reyna left for work at 3:30 AM, a car was waiting for her. And it followed her the whole way there. She got on the phone with Rob, who was telling her, don't pull over. Just keep going. Car followed her the next day too.
很快，面对面的事开始了。年轻的白人男子在红绿灯路口认出罗伯和雷娜，大喊威胁，然后飞驰而去。一对夫妇在停车场走到雷娜、她的小女儿和六岁的孙子面前开始叫嚣，用着“N”开头的种族歧视词汇。一天早上，雷娜凌晨3:30去上班，一辆车在等她。它一直跟踪她到公司。她跟罗伯通了电话，罗伯告诉她：别停车。一直开。那辆车第二天又跟踪了她。
Reyna says several of the Mathis' kids started having upsetting experiences too. An older daughter was working at a restaurant, and she overheard a group of people saying racist things about Rob and Reyna. She got into an argument with them, and the restaurant fired her. Reyna says most upsetting, though, was how everything changed for her youngest daughter, Asia, who was in middle school at the time.
雷娜说马西斯家的一些孩子也开始经历不安的事情。一个大女儿在餐馆工作，听到一群人对罗伯和雷娜发表种族主义言论。她跟他们争论，餐馆解雇了她。不过，雷娜说最令她不安的是，对于当时上中学的最小女儿亚希娅，一切都改变了。
She had friends that told her they couldn't talk to her anymore.
她有朋友告诉她不能再跟她说话了。
Oh my gosh.
天哪。
She came home one day and said she was sitting with her friend at school at the lunch table, and the little girl's mother called her. And she told her she was sitting with Asia. And she said, well, tread lightly. You know, don't trust her. And then the--
有一天她回家说，她学校午餐时跟朋友坐在一起，那个小女孩的妈妈给她打了电话。她告诉她正跟亚希娅坐在一起。她说：“小心点。你知道，别相信她。”然后——
She said that to her daughter?
她对她女儿那么说？
And my daughter could hear her. Yeah, she was on the phone with her mom during lunch. And my daughter could hear. The little girl asked my daughter, she said, what color are you again? My mom wants to know. Asia said, well, I'm mixed. And she goes, oh, she's mixed or whatever. And that's when she told her to tread lightly, don't trust her. And then the next day, the girl didn't talk to my daughter no more. And she hasn't talked to her since.
我女儿听到了。是的，午餐时她在跟妈妈通电话。我女儿听到了。那个小女孩问我女儿：“你到底是什么颜色的？我妈想知道。”亚希娅说：“哦，我是混血。”然后她就说：“哦，她是混血什么的。”那是她告诉她要“小心点，别相信她”的时候。第二天，那个女孩就不再跟我女儿说话了。直到现在也没再说过。
So she kind of went into the stage where she didn't want to go to school anymore. She said she wanted to move and just not be around here. And that was the most hurtful to me. Because my other kids are grown. They can deal with stuff like that. She's-- you know, she's a very lovable little girl, and she loves everybody.
所以她进入了一个阶段，不想再去学校了。她说她想搬家，不想待在这儿了。那对我伤害最深。因为我的其他孩子都成年了。他们能应付那种事。而她——你知道，她是个非常可爱的女孩，她爱所有人。
And she just felt like she lost everything. And that hurt me, because it felt like it was because of us. But it was really because of him.
她觉得自己失去了一切。那伤害了我，因为我觉得那是我们造成的。但实际上是那个人造成的。
The impact of all of this on the Mathis' lives, they pulled their house off the market, because they didn't want any cars they didn't know pulling up. They were stressed. Rob and Reyna told me they were on edge and arguing, including about whether all this had been worth it. There was also another source of stress, particularly for Rob. And I want to tell you this part of the story because of how important it was to him, and of how important it was to how he saw all of this.
所有这一切对马西斯生活的影响，他们把房子从市场上撤了下来，因为他们不想让不认识的车开过来。他们压力很大。罗伯和雷娜告诉我他们处于崩溃边缘，经常争吵，包括是否这一切都值得。还有另一个压力来源，特别是对罗伯。我想告诉你这部分故事，因为这对他来说非常重要，这对于他如何看待这一切至关重要。
The night I first interviewed Rob and Reyna, this came up. After we'd spent several hours talking, I was getting ready to leave. And he was showing me some of the threats he'd gotten on Facebook. Then he referred a couple times to when I was attacked. I did not understand what he was talking about, so I asked him. Then he pulled down his shirt collar, and he showed me an enormous scar.
我第一次采访罗伯和雷娜那天晚上，谈到了这个。聊了几个小时，我准备离开。他给我看了一些他在脸书上收到的威胁。然后他几次提到“我被袭击的时候”。我不明白他在说什么，所以问了他。然后他拉下衬衫领子，给我看了一道巨大的伤疤。
And so that goes-- just because it's on the radio-- it goes from, like, the--
所以那一直——仅仅为了在电台里说清楚——那伤疤从——
From my right ear down to my Adam's apple-- staples. There's a lot. There was a lot.
从我右耳一直延伸到喉结——全是缝合的钉子。有很多。非常多。
From there, the scar continued down onto Rob's chest. It turned out, decades before all this, when Rob was 19, a young soldier in the Army, he went out to a club with a few other soldiers. In the parking lot, Rob passed a guy sitting on a car. And he said, what's up?
那道伤疤继续延伸到罗伯的胸口。原来，早在这一切之前的几十年前，罗伯19岁时，作为陆军的一名年轻士兵，他和其他几名士兵去俱乐部。在停车场，罗伯经过一个坐在车上的家伙。他说：“怎么了？”
And he said, you what's up, you know? He was like, you [BLEEP] N-words.
他说：“你问怎么了？”他当时说：“你这该死的黑鬼。”
This guy jumped Rob, and he cut his throat. He sliced both his carotid artery and his jugular vein. Rob got rushed to the hospital. When he woke up, he had burns on his chest from defibrillation. He'd had a stroke.
那家伙跳下车袭击了罗伯，割断了他的喉咙。他割开了他的颈动脉和颈静脉。罗伯被送往医院。当他醒来时，胸口有电击除颤留下的灼伤。他中风了。
He couldn't speak. He couldn't feel his legs. He couldn't move them. He was paralyzed. It took years of rehab before he could regain his ability to speak, to walk, to use his hands.
他无法说话。感觉不到腿。无法移动它们。他瘫痪了。经历了数年的康复训练，他才重新获得说话、走路、使用手的能力。
In the beginning, it was like five years before I could walk without a cane. I can't pick up a pen with this hand, you know? I got to look at what I'm doing with this hand and tell it what to do. Can't just do it.
刚开始，我花了五年时间才不用拐杖走路。我不能用这只手拿起一支笔，你知道吗？我得看着这只手，告诉它怎么做。不能直接动。
Because you don't have the sensation in your fingers.
因为你的手指没有感觉。
Right. I mean, it's been a struggle all my life. There's not a day that go by that I don't think about it. And you know, I think about the situation at least once a day, that this man stole my life from me because he was racist. I would've achieved my military goal and been Sergeant Major Mathis. That was what I wanted to be. But he stole that from me, you know?
是的。我这一生都在挣扎。没有哪一天我不去想它。而且你知道，我至少每天想一次那件事，那个男人因为种族歧视偷走了我的人生。我本可以实现军事目标，成为马西斯军士长。那是我想要的。但他偷走了那个目标，你知道吗？
And it changed me as a person to where I'm a little more cautious, and I pay attention to details. So with that situation when we went to that looking for a home to buy, and I seen that application on the wall, it wasn't even-- I couldn't stay in that house no more. I had to get out.
这改变了我的性格，我变得谨慎多了，我也注意细节。所以在那次看房找房子的经历中，当我看到墙上的那份申请书，我简直——我不能再待在那栋房子里了。我必须离开。
These two experiences sat on top of each other for Rob. They blurred together. What he'd seen that day in Anderson's house, it placed him back in that feeling from that parking lot, when he was attacked out of nowhere and nearly killed.
这两段经历对罗伯来说重叠在了一起。它们模糊在一起。那天他在安德森家看到的东西，让他回到了停车场的那种感觉：在那儿他毫无防备地被袭击，差点被杀。
I've had that feeling for over 40 years, the feeling of, OK, you know, something's wrong, but I'm going to keep going, you know? At the bar, I was having a good time. But when the guy jumped off the car and said, you what's up, you know, and when he started hurling the slurs at me, like, it went from good to bad like that. So walking through this house, I'm like, OK, it's good. It's a nice house, this, that, and the other. But every step of the way, it was just like, nah, nah. It just changed, changed, changed.
那种感觉伴随我40多年了，“好的，你知道有些不对劲，但我得继续往前走”。在酒吧时，我玩得很开心。但当那家伙跳下车，说“你问怎么了”，当他开始向我投掷种族蔑称时，一切从好变坏，就是那样。所以走进那栋房子，我在想：“好的，这不错，是一栋好房子。”但每一步，这感觉都在改变。
So that feeling of that racism was from the time he opened his mouth, and it was from the time we walked through the door of this house. Every step I took in that house made me feel more and more that this is racism, racism, racism. Let's go. Nothing to talk about. Nothing to say.
那种种族主义的感觉从他开口那一刻就有了，从我们走进那栋房子的那一刻就有了。我在那栋房子里的每一步，都让我觉得这就是种族主义、种族主义、种族主义。让我们走吧。没什么可谈的。没什么可说的。
Both of these experiences, four decades apart, came with the question, what would the institutions in charge do about it? In Kentucky, where Rob was stabbed, what the government did ultimately didn't amount to much. Police arrested Ron's attacker that night and recovered the switchblade he used at a parking lot full of witnesses. But the man seems to have served only two months for assault under extreme emotional disturbance before he was released on probation.
这两段相隔四十年的经历，都带出了一个问题：掌权的机构会对此做什么？在罗伯被刺伤的肯塔基州，政府最终采取的行动没起到什么作用。警方当晚逮捕了罗伯的袭击者，并在满是目击者的停车场找回了折叠刀。但那个人在极端情绪干扰下，似乎只因为袭击服刑了两个月，就被假释了。
Flash forward 40 years to Muskegon, Michigan. How will the city handle a police officer accused of mistreating people of color and who's discovered to have racist memorabilia in his house?
时间快进40年，来到密歇根州马斯基根。这座城市将如何处理一位被指控虐待有色人种，且被发现家中存有种族主义纪念品的警官？
We get to that in our next act, Act 7-- The Investigation.
我们在下一幕中详细介绍，第七幕：调查。
The one time in this whole process that we get a chance to hear Charles Anderson's side of this is when the police department's investigators brought him in for questioning. I don't have audio of this. I just have a transcript. It indicates Anderson sat down with a high-ranking officer working on the investigation, Captain Shawn Bride, six days after the Mathis' Facebook post. Anderson brought a police union representative to the meeting.
在整个过程中，我们有机会听到查尔斯·安德森这一面之词的唯一机会，是警察局的调查人员带他去审讯时。我没有音频。我只有一份笔录。它显示，在马斯基根发布脸书帖子六天后，安德森与参与调查的一名高级警官肖恩·布莱德队长坐在一起。安德森带了一名警察工会代表参加了会议。
Right in the early questioning, Captain Bride asks Anderson to explain the KKK application. Anderson says, quote, "What it is is this is an antique room. Nobody-- nobody ever used it. That item was on the wall because I didn't take the items off the wall, just because I thought it would look better for selling. And I didn't even realize it was on there. I mean, yes, it's mine. Yes, I collect. But I didn't know that specific item was on the wall. I didn't really pay attention."
在早期质询中，布莱德队长要求安德森解释那份三K党申请书。安德森说：“这实际上是一个古董收藏室。没——从来没人用过它。那个东西在墙上，是因为我没有把墙上的东西取下来，我以为卖房子时那样更好看。我甚至没意识到它在上面。我的意思是，是的，那是我的。是的，我收藏。但我不知道那具体的东西在墙上。我没怎么注意。”
Anderson then tells the investigator he bought the application at a flea market for $20 or $30. The investigator asks, why? What possessed you to buy something that looks like that and contains that information? Anderson replies, it's part of history, and I love history. And I have thousands of antiques, and I could show them to you. I have thousands.
安德森随后告诉调查员，他是花20或30美元在跳蚤市场买的。调查员问：为什么？是什么驱使你去买看起来那样、且包含那种信息的东西？安德森回答：这是历史的一部分，我热爱历史。我有成千上万件古董，我可以带你看。我有成千上万件。
Next, they talk about the Confederate flags. Anderson tells the investigator, if you go downstairs, I have a very, very large collection of Dukes of Hazzard. You probably know, but The Dukes of Hazzard was a TV show in the '80s which featured a muscle car named the General Lee, which had a Confederate flag painted on the top. And Anderson's love of the show does seem real. Muskegon's city manager told me, at one point, Anderson was bringing his lunch to work in a Dukes of Hazzard lunch box.
接下来，他们谈到了邦联旗。安德森告诉调查员，如果你去楼下，我有一个非常、非常庞大的《杜克兄弟》（Dukes of Hazzard）收藏。你可能知道，那是一部80年代的电视剧，特色是一辆名叫“李将军”的肌肉车，车顶上画着邦联旗。安德森对这部剧的热爱似乎是真实的。马斯基根的城市经理告诉我，有一段时间，安德森带着《杜克兄弟》的午餐盒去上班。
Anyway, Anderson goes on here about the TV series, how he's gone a few times to a fan event called Dukesfest down South. Quote, "I have an original script signed by Cougar. My wife bought it for me. I actually owned a car that was painted like the General Lee. I have all their videos. I watch them all the time. I love The Dukes of Hazzard, and that's the reason for the Confederate flags. They mean nothing other than it was part of that collection."
总之，安德森继续谈论这个电视系列剧，说他去过几次南方参加名为“杜克节”的粉丝活动。他说：“我有一份原版剧本，上面有Cougar签名。是我妻子买给我的。我甚至真的有一辆像‘李将军’那样涂装的车。我有他们所有的视频。我一直看它们。我热爱《杜克兄弟》，这就是邦联旗的原因。它们除了作为收藏的一部分，毫无意义。”
Captain Bride, the investigator, seems to try to help Anderson with this point he's building. Bride says, "So would I be safe in summarizing, as some folks are big fans of college football, people are fans of sailing, you're a fan of The Dukes of Hazzard?" "Yes," says Anderson, "I love them."
调查员布莱德队长似乎试图帮助安德森建立这个观点。布莱德说：“那我可以这样总结吗：就像有些人是大学橄榄球的铁粉，有些人是航海爱好者，你是《杜克兄弟》的粉丝？”“是的，”安德森说，“我热爱它们。”
As they continue, Anderson flatly denies being a member of the KKK and says he didn't leave these items up to discourage people of color from buying the house. The investigator asks, so a Black Jew from Ethiopia would be welcome if they met your asking price? Yes, they would, says Anderson. Then there's a string of moments like that one, where it feels like the investigator, Captain Bride, is trying to throw Anderson life preservers, like a long stretch where they talk through things that Anderson was commended for, including how he stopped two men, in separate incidents, from killing themselves.
继续质询时，安德森断然否认自己是三K党成员，并说他并没有把这些物品留在墙上以劝阻有色人种购买这栋房子。调查员问：如果一个来自埃塞俄比亚的黑人犹太人出得起你的叫价，你会欢迎吗？“是的，欢迎，”安德森说。随后是一连串类似的问题，感觉调查员布莱德队长试图扔给安德森救生圈，比如一大段关于他们谈论安德森被嘉奖的事情，包括他如何防止两名男子在不同事件中自杀。
Investigators ask about each man's race. One was White. The other, who Anderson pulled off a bridge, was Black. Later, when Anderson mentions doing community work with someone whose name is blacked out, the detective responds, "Interesting. It's my understanding that one of the tenants of the Knights of the Ku Klux Klan is that they're strongly against anyone who is-- I guess the most correct way to say it these days is that LBGTQ community. Would it be fair to say that so-and-so is a strong proponent of that community, and maybe even a member?"
调查员询问每个人的种族。一个是白人。另一个安德森从桥上救下的，是黑人。后来，当安德森提到与一个名字被遮盖的人进行社区工作时，侦探回应道：“有趣。据我了解，三K党的一项宗旨是强烈反对任何……我想现在最正确的说法是LGBTQ群体。那能不能说，某某人是那个群体的积极支持者，甚至可能是成员？”
"Yes," says Anderson. "You consider him an associate or a friend?" "I consider him a friend," says Anderson, confirming, yes, he has a gay or trans friend. I asked to talk to Captain Bride about this and other parts of the investigation, but the Muskegon Police. Department said no.
“是的，”安德森说。“你认为他是合作伙伴或朋友？”“我认为他是朋友，”安德森说，证实了是的，他有同性恋或跨性别朋友。我要求和布莱德队长讨论这个问题及调查的其他部分，但马斯基根警察局拒绝了。
There are lots of things Anderson is not questioned about, nothing about the complaints Duke Stalling and his family filed against him after they were pepper sprayed, nothing about any other specific incidents on the job or about how he treated Black people in general, other than a few broad and very generic questions-- if he's ever allowed implicit bias to affect his work. No, Anderson says. Has he treated people unfairly? No. Has he had diversity training? Yes, he has.
有很多事情安德森没被质询，比如公爵·斯托林及其家人在被喷胡椒喷雾后对他提起的投诉，没有任何关于工作表现的具体事件，也没有关于他对待黑人的总体态度，除了一些非常宽泛和笼统的问题——他是否在工作中受隐性偏见影响。不，安德森说。他是否不公平地对待别人？不。他是否接受过多元化培训？是的，他接受过。
Just to be clear, investigators don't get into the details of Anderson's behavior on the job, because Chief Lewis didn't order them to. His instructions were to figure out whether this thing online was accurate. Did Anderson have the flags and the KKK application up in his house, and if so, why? So that's what they confined themselves to.
澄清一下，调查人员并没有深入调查安德森的工作表现，因为刘易斯局长没下令。他的指示是弄清楚网上的事是否属实。安德森家里是否有旗帜和三K党申请书，如果有，为什么？所以他们只局限于此。
Most telling and relevant to our story is the way they wrap up. In the final pages of the transcript, Captain Bride literally invites Anderson to explain away the things he had up in his house. Quote, "For me, Chuck, if you would-- and the pieces have come together for you to do this-- what could you do to explain this away and allow the members of our community to accept you and place their trust in you to be fair and impartial in policing them?"
最能说明问题且与我们的故事相关的是他们结束质询的方式。在笔录的最后一页，布莱德队长简直是在邀请安德森为墙上的东西做辩解。他说：“对于我来说，查克，如果你能——情况摆在这里了——你能做些什么来解释这些，让我们的社区成员接受你，并信任你在警务工作中是公平和公正的？”
Here's how Anderson responds. "I would explain as exactly what I already explained to you, why it was there and that it meant no intent. And I apologize if it did, why it created this mess. I mean, I didn't even know it was up there. And it was a mistake. And I meant no harm against anyone. And I've been an officer for 22 years, and this is the first time something like this has ever came out, you know, like this. And I think I've done well. I've treated everyone fairly. I've never had a problem before like this."
安德森回应道：“我会像刚才向你解释的那样解释，说明它为什么会在那里，它完全没有意图。如果造成了这种混乱，我道歉。我的意思是，我甚至不知道它挂在那里。这是一个错误。我没想伤害任何人。我做了22年警察，这是第一次出现这种情况，你知道，像这样。我觉得我做得很不错。我公平对待每一个人。我以前从没遇到过这样的问题。”
It just didn't make sense, you know what I mean?
这完全讲不通，你明白吗？
One person who did not think Officer Anderson was doing a good job explaining this away was the person who ordered the investigation, Muskegon police chief Jeff Lewis. Lewis told me, at first, sure, the Dukes of Hazzard, American history collector thing seemed possible to him. But he says they asked Anderson to produce evidence of that, pictures of the collection, receipts and stuff. But even with Anderson's job on the line, Lewis says he never did.
一个人认为安德森警官在为这些事做辩解做得很不好，那正是命令调查的人——马斯基根警察局长杰夫·刘易斯。刘易斯告诉我，起初，当然，《杜克兄弟》、美国历史收藏家之类的说法看起来是可能的。但他说他们要求安德森提供证据，收藏品的照片、收据等等。但即使在工作岌岌可危的情况下，刘易斯说他还是没能提供。
Nothing was produced. And I'm not calling him a liar, but I'm just saying that it didn't hold any water. That bucket didn't hold water.
什么都没产出。我不是说他是个骗子，但我只是说那站不住脚。那个水桶盛不住水。
For Lewis, the stuff in Anderson's house seemed pretty damning.
对刘易斯来说，安德森家里的东西似乎非常令人震惊。
Like, let's say I'm really into governors, for instance. And so when you come to my office, I have just one portrait on the wall behind me, Governor George Wallace.
比如，假设我真的很迷恋州长。当你们走进我的办公室时，我身后的墙上只挂着一幅肖像：州长乔治·华莱士。
George Wallace, famous southern segregationist.
乔治·华莱士，著名的南方种族隔离主义者。
But I tell you I'm just into governors. But you see that. Doesn't that governor tell you something? Why is that governor in my office behind me on my wall?
但我告诉你我只是迷恋州长。但你看到了。那个州长难道没告诉你什么吗？为什么那个州长在我的办公室里，挂在我身后的墙上？
After reading Anderson's transcript and talking to the chief, I still didn't really understand what these items meant to him. Was the KKK application some random thing he picked up like he said, or was this something important to him? Rachael Anderson, Officer Anderson's wife, agreed to tell me more if I kept all my questions to the subject of their collecting and how the KKK application fit into it.
在阅读安德森的笔录并与局长交谈后，我仍然不明白这些物品对他意味着什么。三K党申请书是他像他所说的那样随意捡到的杂物，还是对他来说很重要？安德森警官的妻子瑞秋同意，如果我把所有问题都局限在他们的收藏主题，以及三K党申请书是如何归入其中的，她就愿意告诉我更多。
Hello?
喂？
Hi. Rachel?
你好，是瑞秋吗？
Yes.
是的。
Rachel told me she and her husband have collected all kinds of old stuff for decades. They're not history buffs collecting artifacts from the Civil War, or World War II, or anything like that. They're people who stop at flea markets and antique shops and buy stuff randomly.
瑞秋告诉我，她和丈夫几十年来收集了各种旧东西。他们不是收集内战或二战文物之类的历史发烧友。他们是那种在跳蚤市场和古董店随手买东西的人。
Just, if it's old, if it's cool, if we think it's cool or different.
只要是旧的，如果它很酷，如果我们觉得它很酷或与众不同。
Rachael texted me photos of their house, of a room they call the radio room, with 30-some vintage radios on shelves all around, of a room they call the toy room that has old toys, dozens of old lunchboxes and thermoses, some from TV shows like Charlie's Angels and Knight Rider, vintage appliances, pots and tools in the kitchen, a big shelf full of old piggy banks. She says Officer Anderson has a collection of old hair dryers.
瑞秋给我发了他们家的照片，一个他们称为“收音机室”的房间，架子上放着30多个老式收音机，一个称为“玩具室”的房间，里面有旧玩具，几十个旧午餐盒和保温瓶，有些来自《查理的天使》或《霹雳游侠》等电视节目，厨房里有旧电器、锅碗瓢盆，架子上堆满了旧存钱罐。她说安德森警官收藏了旧吹风机。
Oh, I don't know why he likes the hair dryers. He's got some old ones, you know, like handheld ones that have, like, a wooden handle. And there's not really much to them. And then he likes the old colorful ones that they-- they're like, in a round box, and you open them up. I think they're, like, from the '50s.
哦，我不知道他为什么喜欢吹风机。他有一些老式的，你知道，那种有木柄的手持吹风机。没什么特别的。然后他喜欢那种彩色的，放在圆盒子里，打开盖子那种。我想它们大概来自50年代。
As for the Confederate flags and the KKK application, like her husband told investigators, Rachael said the Confederate flags were part of a big Dukes of Hazzard collection.
至于邦联旗和三K党申请书，就像她丈夫告诉调查员的那样，瑞秋说邦联旗是《杜克兄弟》庞大收藏的一部分。
I would like to make one thing clear. I don't know if this-- if this is outstepping my boundary or not. But I am the one that found that specific item that everyone made a big deal about, just saying.
我想澄清一件事。我不知道这是否越界了。但那件每个人都大惊小怪的特定物品，是我发现的，我就这么一说。
Oh, the KKK application?
哦，那份三K党申请书？
Yeah. I was like, hey, this is so cool. This would look awesome in the antique room, just the way it looked.
是的。我当时想：嘿，这太酷了。如果挂在古董室里看起来会很棒，就因为它看起来那个样子。
Huh. Can I ask, like, what your feelings were about that particular artifact?
嗯。能问一下，你对那件特定的文物有什么感受吗？
I didn't really have any. I just thought it was kind of-- it was different. It was cool. Looked, you know, just different. Honestly, it was put on the wall and kind of just forgotten about.
我没觉得有什么。我只是觉得它很特别。它很酷。看起来，你知道，就是与众不同。老实说，它被挂在墙上，然后就慢慢被遗忘了。
Once people had a reaction to that, because of what it's associated with historically, did that change the way that you felt about it?
一旦人们因为它的历史关联性产生反应时，那是否改变了你的看法？
Um, not-- it didn't really change the way I felt about it. I just thought it was kind of neat. It was, you know, old. It was part of history.
嗯，没有——它并没改变我的看法。我只是觉得它很整齐。它是旧的，是历史的一部分。
But what about the fact that people were like, that's a scary thing for me to see because of who I am?
但如果人们说：“因为它代表的身份，这对我来说是个可怕的东西”，你怎么看？
I'm not really sure how to answer that. I mean, I'm not saying I don't understand people have feelings. But it's not like that described who we are. And the way things are now, I mean, everybody is offended over something. And who knows what that might be?
我不太确定怎么回答。我的意思是，我不是说我不理解人们有感受。但它并不能描述我们是谁。以现在的形势，每个人都对某件事感到被冒犯。谁知道那会是什么？
I ended up feeling like Officer Anderson's account to investigators had mostly been true. He and Rachael didn't seem like card-carrying members of a White supremacist organization. I can see them buying that KKK application without ever expecting to offend anyone. But it said a lot that even two years later, she didn't seem to understand the fear and concern people had about this thing she thought was cool. And she wasn't really interested in understanding that.
我最终觉得安德森警官对调查员的解释大部分是真实的。他和瑞秋看起来并不像白人至上组织的忠实成员。我可以想象他们买下那份三K党申请书时，根本没想过会冒犯任何人。但即使过了两年，她似乎依然不理解人们对这件她认为很酷的东西感到的恐惧和担忧，这本身就说明了问题。而且她真的没兴趣去理解。
So the city's investigation is going. The Mathises are being harassed. And people are waiting. They're waiting to find out what the city is going to do and say about all this. And this did not play out the way I expected it to. Next time, what the city decides to do about Charles Anderson.
所以城市的调查在进行。马西斯夫妇受到骚扰。人们在等待。他们在等待看市政府会对这一切做些什么和说些什么。事情的发展完全超出了我的预期。下集，看市政府决定如何处理查尔斯·安德森。
Ben Calhoun-- he's one of the editors of our program. One of the things that he did not expect that we get into next time, the tour of Officer Anderson's house. Rob and Reyna had thought this was some random police officer. And they were shocked to learn that they'd crossed paths with him years before, an incident that they did remember very vividly.
本·卡尔洪——他是我们节目的编辑之一。他没预料到下集我们将深入探讨的一件事，是安德森警官房子的参观过程。罗伯和雷娜本来以为这只是个偶然路过的警察。他们惊讶地发现，原来他们几年前就与他发生过交集，那是一次他们记得非常清晰的事件。
I'm like, Reyna, just be cool. Be cool. Be cool. And he said, you're resisting. You're resisting. And then he swung her around, and he threw her on the hood of the car. I was worried that he was going to shoot her in front of me and the kids.
我心想：雷娜，冷静点。冷静。冷静。他说：“你在反抗。你在反抗。”然后他把她转过去，把她按在车盖上。我当时很担心他会在我和孩子们面前开枪打死她。
That's next time, on our show.
那是下集内容，在我们的节目里。
[MUSIC - "O ME O MY" BY SON LITTLE]
[音乐 - Son Little的《O ME O MY》]
Our program was produced today by Ben Calhoun, me, with help from Zoe Chace and Dana Chivvis. Contributing editors for today's program, Stephen Henderson and Rob Wildeboer. Original music for today's show by Matt McGinley. The other people who helped put together today's program-- Elna Baker, Sean Cole, Michal Comite, Aviva DeKornfeld, Damien Grave, Chana Joffe-Walt, Stowe Nelson, Katherine Rae Mondo, Will Peischel, Robin Semien, Alissa Shipp, Laura Starecheski, Lilly Sullivan, Christopher Swetala, Matt Tierney, and Diane Wu. Our managing editor is Sarah Abdurrahman. Our senior editor is David Kestenbaum. Our executive editor is Emanuele Berry.
今天的节目由本·卡尔洪和我制作，佐伊·蔡斯和达娜·奇维斯协助。本期节目的编辑是斯蒂芬·亨德森和罗伯·威尔德波尔。原创音乐由马特·麦金利提供。协助完成今天节目的还有——埃尔娜·贝克、肖恩·科尔、米哈尔·科米特、阿维瓦·德科恩费尔德、达米安·格雷夫、查纳·乔夫-沃尔特、斯托·尼尔森、凯瑟琳·雷·蒙多、威尔·佩舍尔、罗宾·塞米恩、阿丽莎·希普、劳拉·斯塔雷切斯基、莉莉·沙利文、克里斯托弗·斯韦塔拉、马特·蒂尔尼和黛安·吴。管理编辑是萨拉·阿卜杜拉赫曼。高级编辑是大卫·克斯滕鲍姆。执行编辑是伊曼纽尔·贝里。
Special Thanks today to Eric Hood, Destiny Keener-Sargent, Jen White, Dustin Dwyer, Paul Butler, Sharon Fairley, Craig Futterman, Tracey Mears, and Timothy Maat. Our website, ThisAmericanLife.org, where you can stream our archive, over 750 episodes, for absolutely free. Also, there's video, lists of favorite programs, tons of other stuff there too. Again, ThisAmericanLife.org.
特别感谢埃里克·胡德、德斯蒂尼·基纳-萨金特、珍·怀特、达斯汀·德怀尔、保罗·巴特勒、莎伦·费尔利、克雷格·富特曼、特雷西·米尔斯和蒂莫西·马特。我们的网站ThisAmericanLife.org，您可以在那里免费流媒体收听我们的存档，超过750集。还有视频、最受欢迎节目列表，以及海量内容。再次提醒，ThisAmericanLife.org。
This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia. You know he visited the United Nations building in New York City last weekend, was not a fan of the decorations.
《美国生活》通过PRX公共广播交易发送给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢本节目的联合创始人托雷·马拉蒂亚先生。您知道他上周末参观了纽约市的联合国大厦，但他对里面的装饰不是很感冒。
There was, like, one flag here, one flag there. And I said something like, this is a lot of flags.
这儿有一面旗，那儿有一面。我说了一些类似“这旗子也太多了”的话。
I'm Ira Glass, back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯，下周带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。